[Music]
in amazing rubber news hmm by Ecuadorian
oh man
I don't know Escobar's Ecuadorian Jamaa
lien a woman completed a 31 mile trail
run in very unlikely running gear
flip-flops are why you go home imagine
chant heartbeat or something this is
longer than a marathon 31 miles walking
is very tiring
yes she was running though this whole
team [ __ ] I'm sorry
31 miles is freakin crazy yeah Prezi so
her name is Maria Novella meters say
that again Mario Ramirez Janna Sochi the
22 year old woman from Mexico's
Parramatta this is that runners tribe oh
[ __ ] yeah this is what you look like
running that everyone from the tribe it
ran like that yes your pocket talk last
reward chanclas me out of recycled tire
yep told you that and with the skirt and
she had a scarf and she was just
carrying a bottle of water the whole
time and address you know that whole
barefoot movement yeah and people like
you see all these hipster why people
barefoot it and running and all that and
then you know those shoe glove being
yeah all this started because a guy
studied this try runner yet and these
guys they [ __ ] on it for fun they
just won miles and miles and everybody
from this drive like to get to this
remote area you can't get there on car
horseback or anything and to deliver
messages and all that stuff you have to
run so they do is they'll just drink
this like
he loved that aka corn for are you
Gringo's here yeah
Jean corn berry drink the see lot that
beer and then you notice a dresser and a
lot
cerveza mucho muy bueno and then I'm
gonna do the rest of this in Spanish
esta muy bueno win any chance a panicky
its desta a pero mucho de run off
Coran call it off is muy bien
basically they do that right and that's
the carbs that they need because they're
[ __ ] skinny dude and they barely eat
and the trunk now yeah but they load up
so they load up on this this this
fermented corn [ __ ] right and that like
they just load up on that and that gives
them the energy to just go up not only
that's what they see running as a fine
art and they're saying that they it's
like part of a lot of their religious
ceremonies as well as traditional games
and competitions and like men women and
children all participate in running in
this and my children they are the object
of the beam or a turn hey Raja generate
don't go computer is not a lightning
bolt the [ __ ] beam is you know I love
this to me no no because you gotta be
ready
[ __ ] carb felt like yourself you know
but it makes sense though like we are
meant to run barefoot you know and if
you've been building the calluses and
everything since your little I
absolutely hate running this I don't
like it either but it's this thing that
we can do when we're old as [ __ ] running
and swimming I wish I could run it is
not cool sprinting but your body is made
to do this for a long time
Charlie impact on your joy when I see
runners run though I'm like I would like
running if I ran like you
yes I know the speed that they're going
on it's almost like they have a built-in
motor file you see the wind blowing and
I'm running out [ __ ] sweat am I crazy
I could barely get my [ __ ] shirt to
blow in the wind I'm like why am i using
so much energy I'm moving so [ __ ]
slow hey you know I get your brother
would maybe so my brother actually
really loves running so if you'd like
help I ran out so let's say this dude
doesn't run in like two years right
he'll get on a treadmill and he could
run like four miles right after that
oh my god could do it really well he
blisters he could have thrown out right
so he would like try to take me jogging
is [ __ ] I get so mad this book they were
going right and also hey so how did they
I'm going to stop [ __ ] talking you
have been like I'm trying to like I'm
holding on to life right now and how
does cuz I can't this is what happens
right you do it you would understand you
cross country i'ma show you would have
to do you like this right we're going
right I said to deport them out this
corner so you like here hey so what you
want to eat tonight and this meat does
have to talk cuz it get boring it does
before I can't talk because that's
energy business so but the thing is that
you can build up to that because I was
exactly like that in the very beginning
because like with all my other
impossible oh yeah yeah it's hot it's
possible I will say it like this too
though cuz when I was jogging I told my
brother Alda a should a muscle right
here hurt you Lou that's a heart attack
Oh like slow down my fork started
hurting like oh my god Tina you're
giving us on my credit we don't have it
in our DNA I can just relax Gary I never
had it until I thought you have a long
legs what do you suppose of you guys are
Mexican
do you [ __ ] be her ladyship your
Wendy and you can get really low it has
to be built because I remember running
down the block for me was like I can't
do this [ __ ] I can't breathe but that's
also have smoker lungs and [ __ ] but then
even though I think right when when I
built myself up up to it even though I
[ __ ] run like march of the Penguins I
built it up and once you pass that home
it's like a different it's like a way
different run now doing we used to run
together like down here and going down
the hill and all
I thought I would be so far away from
all the entire group because I'm going
to all go to the park and I would see
you running agree like the furthest one
ahead I'm like honey shoes is repetitive
but I'm dying inside but you look so
grateful - can you just like yeah
[ __ ] right I'm I David Leslie you
should look at my face when I run dude
it looks like I'm running from a [ __ ]
liar if we were to run together right
now I'll probably be as out of breath as
you are that's impossible
I doubt that you ran cross country code
I've seen you chase him down for his
birthday video you were [ __ ] more
lightning Jenny no just just like you
I'm competitive and I really wanted to
catch Hart
so did ice I hated him I wanted to you
know sigh I started realizing that I was
getting older because me and my best
friend we were he was helping me John
he's actually relatively fit and he was
up to me John at night in Sacramento
he's hot during the summer but he was
let's go sprint and I sprint it and then
I felt something pull on my quad that
was the first time I ever felt like a
muscle just detach for no [ __ ] reason
you don't matter
no but when you're yelling you don't
have to warm up you don't pull [ __ ] it
just works yeah I wasn't even that well
say what 26 at the time no all those a
lot younger actually I was like 22 I was
like right off the Riverside no you I
have to stretch now yeah this is crazy
yeah so this is what the trail looks
like heading no she's just wearing
sandals well you guys don't like the
runner side I do like all [ __ ] good
that's what makes me want to keep
running I like the sweepers hi because
she was running through all of this you
can't experience
so one thing is um I hate treadmills
right because it's not you're not going
anyway
whirring but trails like that if it's
almost mad it does it does something to
my spirit like it makes me feel like a
[ __ ] animal like you ah I'm gonna get
my [ __ ] boot like a cheetah I
couldn't run like that in my dream in my
dream
I feel like I'm just I feel the wind and
the energy and then the everything's
changing and then I see the terrain
changing and the challenge of going up
and down and like everything looks great
and you're like running through the
[ __ ] River and all that stuff and I
just feel like a human like catching my
prey or running away from a rapist my
favorite running environment is a
treadmill whether there's AC and I'm
watching ancient aliens that could run
for like an hour straight legs are just
really afraid that's pretty boring it
makes me want to relax no I think just
running and missing out and all that is
boring I'd rather hike and play and do
all that and then maybe run for a little
bit if I want and then just stop and
then grants gonna start with basic I
just gotta walk so you know I start
getting out of that first which it isn't
rewarding to run as fast as you can
uphill gotta get to the top yeah oh my
god you're the only one I feel like the
air is crisp yeah you get excited to see
where you're going - yeah but I can only
run as fast as I can for like 20 seconds
yeah me and I'm done like I asked for
him more than 20 seconds oh yeah I mean
it's sprinting as fast as you can and
then you're kind of like you're at that
point I'm [ __ ] tired but then I feel
good going up and then once you catch
your breath you go up again for 10 or
whatever and then you slow down I get
billing is when you run down the hill
yeah when you feel like you're gonna
fall yes you're don't fall use lean
forward and then you're like if I trip
on a [ __ ] walk I could die right now
kids - just go with the momentum because
if you try stopping you're gonna end up
hurt you guys what about you you guys me
rocky does your teeth hurt yeah [ __ ]
ki 30 share some reason I don't know
what weight like the actual teaser like
a shot I'm out it feels like like the
actual root of your teeth yeah I like it
hurt yeah I don't know
I was like do I feel like you're giving
up on me dude I'm telling you I'm not a
runner
how does how does how do you guys all
feel that what do I have a room like
what yeah my peeper like your [ __ ] stop
every single one is advising me to stop
they're like like having a conversation
with each other like what the [ __ ] is
just been doing you know that's what
they're saying you're like ah like the
outside I'm like nah man keep on doing
it they just might even hurt but like it
gets dry because I'm like when you're
bored you're smiling and running [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] ha ha ha yeah [ __ ]
maniac there's nobody that even cheated
that is smile when they [ __ ] run it
that's what they're supposed to do this
with like oh don't worry my love it
first like if my lung could make it I
think it could well the body shuts down
at the same time they did all agree with
each other how are you guys it's
possible you just gotta build up to it
you have to build up to it yeah yeah you
do with asthma I have asthma
yeah I used to run to the park and do it
like three circuits and run back the
wrong guy let's go again Jen I don't why
did you get a decent I have a high heart
in my shoes I mean my feet - we've got
an advantage for distance runners we
know that crap it's from not doing it
enough oh sure that crap is like we're
doing it out of nowhere because I had
that - its plantar fasciitis or some
[ __ ] like that happen to me all the time
every day it's basically because your
tendons and everything is so tight it's
not used to it and it's not getting that
motion so all of a sudden you're doing
it out of nowhere and then it's Terry
stretch it or something no you have to
exercise motor steps I'm sorry the
reason why a lot of it is hard is
because you're going over your limit so
it's like this like just do like a
minute a day a minute of jogging just
one minute and just stop and it next
just builds up five minutes whatever
like do what's comfortable first and
then challenge yourself because I think
what a lot of people do is they try to
do what other people do so it's super
challenging you can't do like
over a mile and then you're like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] you don't want to do anything
yeah and I'm probably the worst runner
out there because according to bar I
have like type 2 like muscle fibers
which is only meant for like short
bursts of energy you're meant to be a
sprinter yeah I meant to be a sprinter
and then like I'm flat-footed too which
like causing me a whole bunch of
problems where I can be like more easily
- like shin splints like even like hip
injuries like I'm not meant to be a
distance runner if I enjoy distance
running that's because you're Romanian
hey guys I hope you liked that episode
of just continues if you did please
press the like button to show us how
much you love it and for more videos
click right up here